could this be the new home of the House
of Lords York just two hours from Kings
Cross by train and the front-runner for
the new home of Parliament's upper
chamber Boris Johnson is determined to
prove his party is serious about
rebalancing the country and part of that
plan could see the Lord's relocated and
the Commons go on tour around the
country what we are looking at is a
whole range of options about making sure
that every part of the UK feels properly
connected from politics when the Prime
Minister stood up the day after the
general election and said this is going
to be the people's government he meant
it but the idea has critics some say
it's a plan to slim down the number of
peers in the House of Lords and others
have branded it a gimmick I think at
first sight it sounds quite a good idea
in some respects but it doesn't solve
the two problems that I think the Prime
Minister's trying to solve first
legitimacy of the House of Lords which I
think you only solve by having it
democratically elected secondly more
priority to the north and the way you do
that in my view is to have more
devolution of powers to the north and
more resources to the north simply
putting the lords in New York does
nothing to help on any of those fronts
while others think it could be a
positive change I think we've seen very
clearly that many people in the UK not
in the southeast not in London feel out
of touch with the government and feel
that things aren't being run on their
behalf and I think all kinds of ways of
moving things out of out of London
really does go some way to making people
feel they've got more connection with
those decisions Boris Johnson wants to
reconnect the country the better
broadband better buses and now
potentially by moving politics closer to
people leaving the Lord's out of London
is a big ambitious step for a parliament
still ruled by tradition so would it
help solve trust in politics or a
critics right to call this a gesture
what are the people of York make of the
plan it's very funny you know a
diversionary tactic to sort of move us
away from what should be considered
which is abolition of the Lord's really
yeah
how cuz it's too far away you feel like
you're not included in anything yeah
yeah how do you think people's idea
moving the Lord's is just part of a much
bigger constitutional revamp that
government is considering but with a big
majority in the Commons Boris Johnson
has the freedom to shake things up it'll
take all his political capital to make a
plan like this reality Kate McCann Sky
News